Hi, everyone.
My name is Alex Farach.
Welcome to
Let's start at the beginning -
bits the character encoding
and.
I'm a data scientist
and analytics manager
at Accenture Federal Services.
I spend a lot of time thinking
about R, NLP, data viz,
and statistical learning.
My most recent work is on
the Hugging Face R package
to bring Hugging Face
models and tools to R.
So how would you describe the
letter A to a computer? Today,
I'll discuss how.
In doing so, we'll
get into the shallow
end of a deep pool known
as bits to character
encoding, and we'll
talk a little bit of what
that looks like in R. So
what do we mean by bits
to character
encoding, especially
in relationship to
NLP? Well, computers
don't speak the same
language as we do.
If we want to use computers
to process language,
you need some way to encode
language so that computers
understand and vice versa.
Both the encoding and
the decoding process
needs to be identical
on both ends
or the human computer
translation falls apart.
The agreed upon method
is called a protocol.
So back to the question how
would you describe the letter A
to a computer?
Well, we do so by using
numbers, of course,
to represent letters.
So instead of A we can have
1, V it could be 2, and so on.
We assign a number to
represent each unique character
or symbol
we want to communicate. Computers
store numbers in binary,
obviously, and all
signals inside a computer
have two possible
values, 0 or 1.
Each of the 0/1 pieces of
information are called bits.
One bit can represent two value.
Two bits can represent
four, three bits
represent eight, and so on.
So how many bits is needed
to represent 256 values?
Using the logic, just discussed,
it's 8 bits.
When computers were
first developed,
the decision was made that a
byte was the next standard unit
above a bit.
A byte is defined as 8 bits.
In the 1960s,
computer developers
had one byte to work with.
They developed a protocol
to fit into this one byte
called ASCII.
This protocol can
assign a unique number
to all letters in
the English language,
plus numbers, symbols
and control characters.
Everything fits into
this one-byte budget.
And even better, seven
of the available 8 bits
were needed. Over time,
the need to fit
more information grew
larger, but luckily there
was the extra bit to work with.
Things got standardized
into the Latin-1,
which uses the full 8 bits
available in the single byte.
So then after that, a new
standard was developed,
UTF-8.
Each character in UTF-8 is
represented using a prefix U,
followed by a four-digit
hexadecimal number.
The difference between binary
and hexadecimal numbers
are out of scope
for this brief talk.
But what's important
to note here,
though, is that UTF-8
converts a code
point or a single
character in Unicode
and to a set of 1 to 4 bytes
and can encode all 1 million
plus Unicode code points.
Characters strings in R can
be encoded in Latin-1 UTF-8
or as raw bytes.
These declarations
can be read or changed
using the encoding function.
The concept of native
encoding is important here.
Natively encoded strings are
strings written in whatever
code page the user is using.
As of the 4.2.0 release, R
uses UTF-8 as the native encoding.
Prior to this release,
that was not the case
because Windows versions
prior to Windows 10 didn't
allow it. Post Windows 10,
this was allowed and R
was updated to take
advantage of this feature.
This is an exciting change
for us focusing on NLP in R
since it mitigates a lot
of potential problems
for common NLP tasks.
It's also helpful
to keep this in mind
when using common functions like
read.csv where character encoding
can be set. On Linux,
Linux, and Mac OS,
the native encoding
has been UTF-8,
so this isn't an issue there.
Native encoding is why we
see unknown here as well.
For example, we see
coffee as unknown,
even though it's
clearly ASCII compliant.
ASCII strings will never be
marked with a declared encoding
since the representation
is the same
in all supported encodings.
The sys.getlocale function
will tell you what your
native encoding is.
The localization
information function
is another helpful function.
And lastly, we have the
i convert function,
which uses system facilities
to convert a character
vector between encodings.
So how does the tidyverse
tackle encoding?
We turn to the
stringr library, which
is built on top of the
extensive stringi package.
We can specify the
encoding of a string
with the string convert
function. And for fun,
let's create a
little function here
that applies a random encoding
via the stringi string
encode a list function.
And that's it.
Thanks for hanging out with me.